And, and as much as we're talking
about wrestling, he impressed me.
Stand up. Oh yeah. He cracked
Condamine right hand. He, he,
he's, he stood up enough
to just say, you know,
I'm going to sit here and take a
few and I'm going to give a few.
But then he went to probably what his
game plan was, I would assume. Well,
you have to stand for a
little while because if you
just shoots it and he'll get
caught with a knee or caught with
a punch rushing in. But uh, he,
I mean,
he landed the bigger shot.
There was one big giant shot that was
landed in that fight and it was by hand
and Conner hit him with some pretty good
front kicks to the body and some other
things, but it didn't really
get much off on the feet,
not like classic left Jabs that just break
people down and on the ground he just
got mall. And it's one of those things
where you see that guy in the beginning,
guys fight him off a little
bit and then as the fight,
whereas on he just gets more
and more dominant. They get
more and more exhausted.
Really. This fight just makes
ally Quinta look like a God.
I mean that's the most
impressive thing about it.
Ally Quinten went five rounds with him,
stood toe to toe with him and you know,
gave him at least a struggle.
At least he gave him a bit of adversity,
you know, managed to survive on the
ground much better than Conor did.
Manage to get back up to his feet,
manage this stuff.
A bunch of take downs and on the feet
was a real threat. You know what I mean?
Obviously could be, didn't prepare for
ally quintile. He prepared for Connor.
But ally acquainted didn't
even prepare for five rounds.
The only prepared for three.
So there was so much to that fight.
What do you think will
happen with Conner now?
I'm worried what happens with Khabib.
Yeah,
I hope they sit everybody down and
they'd go, look, everybody's all right.
Come on.
You know the guy who rushed in the
cage and punched Connor in the face,
that guy, that guy should be in
the most trouble cause you know,
the guy just fought four rounds. Got
The fuck beaten out of them. Got Choked.
I heard a lot of people,
there's a lot of silly non experts out
there saying that that wasn't a choke or
that wasn't a neck crank. They don't
know what the fuck they're talking about.
That that is absolutely a neck crank
when someone gets their arm around your
head like that.
And then what they do is they grab it
like this and they pinch the elbow.
They put the forearm
on his back like this.
So as the arm is across the neck and then
they grip it like this and the forearm
goes into the back and as
you're pulling like this,
you're pushing with your forum and
Yanking with your hand is a terrible neck
crank. Um, they call dean lister
actually has a video on it. It's,
he calls it the fulcrum
choke and it's a nasty choke.
So you know, I thought he was going
under the neck here. You can see it here.
Dean lister, who's a world champion,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt and a,
that's my friend Hans. Hans Molin camp
behind them and watch how he does it.
See how he's,
he's grabbing a hold of it and what he's
going to do is he's going to clamp his
hands. Cle grips his hands, and so
it crushes. He's doing it like this.
No, no, no. You can go
right over your face.
He can go over your neck and go over
your face and go over your fucking
cheekbones. It doesn't matter. It
doesn't even have to go under the chin.
If it goes on the chin,
that's awesome,
but you see what's going on with
his forearm. See how he's put push,
pull into with his arms or you could
do it some. Some guys do it like this,
but I think this is probably the best
way to do it, but as you're right here,
this part just digs that elbow.
Yeah, perfect. Perfect example.
See he's pulling on it with his,
his right arm and then his left arm is
pushing down with his forearm on Connor
shoulder. It is a nasty,
nasty net crank and you, your,
your head is getting popped
off and first of all,
that guy could squeeze the shit
out of you. All you have to do.
There's a bunch of guys who
could put you to sleep like that.
Marcello Garcia is one.
He puts guys a cease put guys to sleep
without even getting under the chin.
He just gets your head.
Just get your head in there and squeezes.
Eddie Bravo can do that too.
If he gets your head in there,
you don't even have to,
it doesn't even have to be under the chin.
He just really puts you to sleep
with your own fucking head.
Just wraps it around
your head and squeezes.
It's so tight that no blood is
getting to your brain. Yeah.
So there's a lot of armchair quarterbacks
out there saying that that was a neck
crank.
You are incorrect and a have deanlets
to do that shit to you and you will know
Jocko do that to me. My throat
is still, you don't want it.